the other part you said
is the fact that uh when you wanted to
go interview him he kind of like no i
let my executives talk to but not myself
and you said he's more on the private
side he doesn't like to you know
go and you know talk about those tough
conversations
you know elon musk on the opposite end
he's like
total opposite he'll tweet you know
he'll go
smoke weed with joe he'll go you know
hey
69 000 for the tesla 420
a share we're going to go buy it back
he's a troll master
chess master game all this stuff that he
does
why does bezos like to be more private
rather than
public is it a personality thing or is
it just kind of a you know
he sees way too much risk in being in a
public eye
yeah it's a great question i mean elon i
mean their styles are so different
elon has you know everything that you
described but also he's
you know we can admit maybe that he's
undisciplined uh the tweets are
you know as likely to get him into
trouble either regulatory or legal
as whip his fans into into a frenzy um
it's his it's a style it's been
unmistakably effective
he can do it in part because his
ventures are really inspirational tesla
and um and spacex you know bezos maybe
you know yes there's a personal
personality difference he's so
disciplined
and careful the stories that he tells in
interviews are like polished little
stones that he's
used and deployed over the years i've
heard them all i could probably give the
speech myself
you know at the same time he is uh the
ceo the founder of a company that evokes
much more complicated feelings than
people
you know uh um
and that's you know that's um rightly or
or not um
but it's a retailer it's it's
competition it's
sympathetic small and pop mom and pop
businesses
um it's sort of like in some respects
walmart you know a juggernaut
from afar that reaches into communities
um it employs
tons of people in everyone's local
community it's got complicated kind of
tax relief schemes
and it's a lightning rod it is it is
it's occupied that place in the public
imagination right now where people
both depend on it and in the same breath
after they're clicking the buy now
button they're criticizing it
right i mean and so maybe he has to be
more careful
maybe to sit down and make himself
available like elon does
is in some respects dangerous because
he's going to be asked about
taxes and relationship with the workers
and
competition so i don't i don't know but
he is just more disciplined and careful
and he look it's personality he can't he
he
he can't he's not like a steve jobs or
an elon musk where he can whip up his
followers
into you know a frenzy of fandom it's
just he's a
he's kind of still a geek patrick when
it gets down
to it a nerd so so would you categorize
i mean that's a good way of putting you
would you say
musk jobs gates zuck
you know uh bezos would you kind of say
the personalities where gates is a
little bit more he's been in a public
eye more lately you know
vaccine all this other stuff here's what
we need to do challenges we're facing
but would you kind of put it more on the
gates and zuck side than the elon and
job site
maybe that's true i mean in some ways i
think he tries to be up here
hovering above it you know he's so
strategic
in in what he says and how he talks and
where he does it in some ways it's when
he talks
when he writes a letter to shareholders
when he gives an interview with a fellow
billionaire on a stage somewhere
or when he talks about blue origin a
space company it's tactical
he's trying to deliver a message you
know he's he's you know
one of the things is he's just
incredibly strategic with his time
and so partly it might be that but when
he does talk there's always a goal
and a you know an endgame so i don't
know that he's really even that consumed
with his public image
um i mean he certainly does care about
it because you see him responding to
criticism in his writing and
and his and the speeches he does give
but um i think he just tries to sort of
hover above it and no longer really
cares perhaps and
with a 180 billion dollar fortune maybe
he doesn't have to
uh you know cares that much about
getting people to really understand him
i i think he cares though i think he
cares because he does
yeah because you know he responded to
trump and his guy told him not to do it
and you were kind of talking about it
yourself hey
just let it go jake you know all that
stuff that was gonna let it go no he
responds and they had this little battle
going on back and forth
uh i asked because you know uh
it's an old school style he has like
this whole thing about being in the
public eye is more new school it's not
old school social media has almost
forced a lot of ceos to be in a public
eye generally
you know powerful business people were
like listen
just you know i don't want to do a lot
of interviews you know your publicist
would say don't talk to anybody what if
you say the wrong thing
where today it's more like let me go
handle let me respond back on twitter
let me go do this we have more access so
it does show a lot of discipline to him
internally you know as you did the
interview from the first book to the
second one
obviously on the second one you're
saying you didn't meet with him but he
did allow you to go on interview a lot
of his executive which is great
did you ever read the book accidental
millionaire that was written in the 80s
i want to say
it was a book written in the 80s about
jobs and these were former employees
that left you know the book accidental
billionaire about zuck
prior to accidental billionaire there
was a book called accidental millionaire
and it was written when you read the
book you could tell
it was written by a former employee who
hated
jobs i mean couldn't stand jobs and in
many documentaries when they interviewed
people that worked with jobs at his peak
you know you talk about bully which
we'll get to chapter three here in a
minute
but they say you know uh uh how he was
and how he would you know flip out and
this and that
when you were doing interviews from
people recently
not all not 2013 i'm talking about
recently
and interviewing former people as well
as exec
existing people what things have you
seen evolve in the last eight years from
2012 to 2020 2021
in terms of the corporate culture or
yeah in terms of like let's just say
2003 when you were talking to
disgruntled employees who left they
would say oh he saw this
maybe disgruntled employees that now
left are saying something different and
the people that are there who are happy
are saying something different like
bazel's has changed because of dot dot
dot yeah
well first of all you know yes there are
disgruntled employees
but you know it it's the preponderance
of of the of the workers that i've
interviewed over the years
you know have been i think pretty sort
of a
clear-eyed um you know and frank about
their contributions the the the pride
they took at the work but also
but also the some of the disadvantages
or the you know the leadership style
that
ultimately burned them out so it wasn't
it's not quite disgruntled it sometimes
exhausted her
or you know post-traumatic stress
disorder from being
lashed to a rocket ship you know
captained by a ceo who just never
stopped
and in the early years they described
this
leadership style that was brusque and
demanding and sometimes demeaning and
intimidating
and in the first book the everything
store i tell all sorts of stories of
bezos saying
remarkable things you know like why are
you wasting my life
and then and amazon unbound that
leadership style has matured somewhat
um you know he he he doesn't you know he
bottles that up
uh and you know but he still has
incredibly high standards
and he'll walk out of a room if he feels
like employees haven't solved the
problem
or ha aren't betting big enough or
thinking big enough or don't have an
ingenious solution to something
i tell the story in amazon unbound of
alexa
and the creation of alexa which she
sponsored and got into the details of it
it's really
you know this lesson for i think anybody
in business of you know
how just having the idea isn't enough
but you have to as a ceo sort of use
your leadership magic to sponsor it
to get into the details to understand
the technical specifications
and then to allow your employees as one
says
quarter in the book is to be unbound you
know to not limit themselves in terms of
how they're thinking or investing the
the big question with
alexa was how they they were going to
test it and ultimately before launch
ultimately they bring it out
into the world uh in disguise
and they rent apartments and houses and
shroud the thing with the acoustic
fabric
and get contractors to go through
reciting scripts and that's the only
reason why i got smart enough to launch
and that was bezos basically pushing his
people so yeah i think the quality the
the tenor of the testimony about the
culture has changed but in some ways
it's just as difficult it's just his
leadership style softened a little bit
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye